Thank You Liam well many people feel
that making a healthy home-cooked meal
at home because next to impossible on a
busy weeknight here to debunk that myth
with two great recipes is registered
dietitian Abby sharp thanks so much for
joining us Abby I know where they had
some tense moments trying to get power
machine but I think we're we're in
business we are in business so this is
new technology really making healthy
eating so much more easy and quick and
accessible for Canadians and my
cooking's come a long way you know
really feeling you're talking Liam's
language you want to talk you my
languages I don't really cook and
exactly anything I can zap we can do and
usually people think oh just the
microwave you think of something fast
may be unhealthy rewarming items but
look what you brought in today
absolutely you can make full meals from
scratch and it's about the difference in
technology because your traditional
microwave delivers energy in a linear
energy wave and that's why sometimes you
may be found you get those
inconsistencies those rubbery bits those
hot spots those raw Center you take a
bite of something at one point the other
side is really off so this new Panasonic
cyclonic inverter technology it dishes
out these spinning rays of power and
that's how you get the consistent even
cooking every time so that's why I've
been able to make full meals not just
rewarm the microwave leftover and you
you are making an apple crisp it's a
tropical fruit tropical ring trying to
channel a little warm weather feeling
you know cuz ya getting cold as you know
so we've got all my favorite tropical
fruits banana mango pineapple just a
touch of butter in here hmm I've got
some coconut sugar which is lower on the
glycemic index in your traditional you
know white or brown sugar just a little
bit of whole grain flour a little bit of
cinnamon and nutmeg and I love lime zest
on like everything is like I'm so
fragrant now is the touch in there is my
kind of cook it right if I kind of big
you know I'm always about like on the go
it's got to be crazy so the topping is
going to be some coconut some oats I've
got flax seed which is hot you know high
in protein and fiber good stuff there a
little bit more of that butter to just
bring it all together and so
of that beautiful coconut sugar so we
just mix this all up and so this is
going to go into our our microwave safe
ramekin so you know obviously this I'm
doing a single serve portion of you know
you want to make it a little really
elegant but you could do a family size
because this is nice no microwave I'll
go to add me this is we're not gonna get
it crispy in here it does get crispy
like look at this golden like it's
beautiful golden brown and it's cuz of
that consistent even cooking from the
cyclonic inverter technology and look I
mean I think we're going to do some
veggie chips in a bit too which is kind
of unbelievable yeah right fat-free
completely fat-free so let's just pop
this in the mocha and get her going yep
we're still in business yes wrkn and how
long you zapping this for two and a half
minutes is all you need so go back right
fungo so it says it's a beautiful
electrostatic glass touch control panel
so it's kind of like the smartphone
technology you can add swipe left swipe
right that's kind of how you can add
your time in like that so just let that
go yeah right we gotta wrap up soon but
in terms of the strategy for the chips
what's the strategy so easy just a
little bit of chili powder a little more
of that lime zest into the microwave 30
seconds on high flip it over another 30
seconds one or two more times they get
crispy they get golden they get
gorgeously delicious like that fat free
from your recipes Abbey where can people
go yes cook with cyclonic CA you'll find
all those great recipes right there
we're also doing a giveaway where they
give away earth right here this heavy do
you know you too can make these recipes
at home how do we do that can you email
us at contest at morning show dot CA and
a panasonic cyclonic inverter microwave
damn big yours amazing and we're gonna
just eat some chips and that's incorrect
it's it's like breakfast Abby shark
thank you so much national edition of
the morning show right up next
so where we left on the amex